hey what's up guys and welcome to an
interesting episode of dark souls modded
as you can see how many people have the
Avalon or the demon great hammer when
they first start playing the game but
this this is a mod that gives you those
things this mod gives you a different
weapon every seven seconds and also a
different enchantment or a different
upgrade path as well so we're going to
try and make our way through the
tutorial and see how far we can get
hopefully we don't get too many weapons
that require a really high strength
count the dagger would be good this bow
is pretty useless if I need to use
arrows and it also goes through a
selection of shields as well so this
should be interesting let's see how we
go we should be able to do the asylum
demon without Estes worst comes to worst
I can just wait for a weapon with an
enchantment that's really good or shield
that's really good I guess
anyway should be too hard
five surely does a lot of damage hey
that does a lot of damage okay so the
early game is actually gonna be quite
easy alright so right now we're going to
go and try and take out Havel it's going
to be an interesting fight because every
time you get a new weapon or a new
shield you have to change your play
style accordingly so if I get a shield
all of a sudden I have to be really
defensive and that's just like at the
drop of a hat you have to be really
defensive if I get this bow I can't do
any damage until I get some arrows so
now is like a decent time to backstab
him so we see if we can get in with
Arabia good no change to a short sword a
broken short sword hope note electric
short sword and now it's acestus so you
know we could be really lucky and we
could be really unlucky and get a weapon
that's not going to block me okay this
might do a bit of damage it's raw that
it changes every time so who really
knows what's going to happen time to
wrap the stairs because I have a
crossbow I have a shield so I'm gonna
two-handed and block oh really who
really oh that's gonna kill me
Baxton oh yeah shield attack oh that's
not a shield that's not a shield get
that chain back step going look oh come
on
you mother row this is round 3 with
Quelaag I think another thing that makes
this really difficult is you know not
only do you have to focus on what the
enemy is doing and what you're doing but
you also have to figure out what weapon
you're using and when you can attack
with it what's moveset is and how close
you need to be whether it's a fire
weapon whether it'll damage them you
know and that's the sort of thing you
have to keep an eye on as well as attend
to all the other visual cues that you
have to do in Dark Souls so it's
actually a bit more difficult than you
think
yeah but I time to cross whoop time to
cross the rafters with these guys umm I
can't kick with a crossbow Kenya alright
so this should be pretty easy okay so
we're going to try again and cross the
rafters it's actually a bit difficult
because usually I kick these guys out of
the way but if you have a bow you can't
actually kick so it might be a bit more
difficult than usual I'm just going to
climb the ladder and run
I can run across the whole thing I've
seen speed runners do it all the time so
I'll just copy or theta
oh come on
okay
don't get close to my back to the jump
here good stuff okay so there are a few
places in Anor Londo that are going to
be really tricky to get through one of
them is obviously this area the other
area was the rafters which went pretty
well and usually I parry the guy on the
right and sometimes he falls off and
that's how I usually deal with it but
I'm gonna have to get so many parodies
correct considering my weapons are gonna
change so let's see how we go that's not
good I wanted to pull out his weapon all
right here we go
fall off or fall off taps can hear
applause weapon Chimaera lost weapon
alright that works so I stopped this
playthrough after finishing Ornstein and
SMO because I feel like that's enough
for you to get a gist of what this mod
is like I was actually really scared of
fighting the four kings as well imagine
how hard that dps race would be so
overall it's kind of a gimmicky
playthrough but at the very least it
definitely tests your weapon knowledge
and ability and it makes for some unique
situations and at the end of the day
unique situations are probably what
you're looking for if you've been
playing Dark Souls since release details
on how to use the mod will be in the
description so check it out if you like
you can also change the time between
switching weapons so that might make it
a little bit more bearable although it
is a nuisance when you get stuck with a
weapon that you can't really use also I
just wanted to leave you guys with one
final story I was actually invited out
to the Namco Bandai office in Sydney the
other day to get a good chance at
playing the TGS demo of Dark Souls 2
which is the demo where you fight the
Maronite needless to say after about
four hours of that demo I'm pretty sure
I have a really good feel for Dark Souls
2 so I'll try to put that into words
over the next few weeks the only problem
is that I don't actually have any good
background footage to show while I talk
about it but when I do get that footage
I'll try and make a video talking about
the PvE the PvP and any law facts that
we know so far
there's still a lot of content to be
made on those topics but not a lot of
background footage for them so what
would you like to hear about most
the PvE the fight against the Maronite
maybe the PvE in the beta perhaps or
maybe you'd like to hear about the leak
to law that we know so far
leave a comment below and rate a few
ideas that you like I'll definitely read
all of your suggestions also if you want
to send a message or hear about what's
going on with me then your best bet is
on Twitter and there's a link in the
description down there anyway that just
about does it I'll see you next time
calm down a bit
hopefully you'll fall off and go for the
backstab when he lands but this is
another weapon I can backstab with this
is a shield oh he's getting so close
that's another shield can't really do
much with that can't really do much with
three shields in a row so I'm just gonna
wait for shields actually I don't know
many arrows for that so I can't really
use that one this is another shield been
over this I can't actually hit him with
shields but again again that's like a
sixth shield this I can't really use but
I'm gonna try anyway get that three
damage very nice
that's a dagger can get him in that no
time
yes I know well that does a lot of
damage at least oh invincibility frames
yeah so the shields go down okay there
we go
I'm just going to eat from a distance
with this no not shield after shield
that's it go for the backstab can't do
it gonna move away change to a weapon
best field that's a whip
yeah now be a good time man to go for an
attack
come on a card hit you with days how
many shields are you gonna give me what
are you doing I think he tried to use
his shield r2
yep yep yep good stuff
data Tata Tata Tata Tata Tata Tata
I wonder if there's gonna be any red
poon with you [ __ ] hey what's up guys
and welcome to dark souls modded so
there's a few things to note about what
you're watching the first is that luring
the bone wheels over here it's an
amazing plan and absolutely nothing will
go wrong even though more bone will
skeletons just came around the corner
now to be fine it'll be easy spoiler I
died so this is the permanent gravelord
mod it's one of the simpler mods all it
does is permanently infect every area of
your game with red phantoms as if you're
being grave loaded and if that gets your
sick twisted masochistic mind excited
then this is the mod for you I almost
wasn't gonna make a video on it but my
playthrough of the catacombs was really